Welcome back everyone this will be my brand new
guardians of the galaxy 3 trailer breakdown from
comic con it was one of the other big clips
that they showed off so if you're brand new
to the channel be sure to subscribe to get
all the videos there was a whole bunch of
stuff they showed off a brand new version of
adam warlock they showed off high evolutionary
they even went full loki with high evolutionary
so chukwudi iwuji is playing a version of high
evolutionary they confirmed it we all believed
it early on so it wasn't a huge surprise
the actual surprise was during the guardians
of the galaxy 3 panel when they went full
loki with him he rolled in in full costume and
in full character like addressing the entire
crowd as if he was actual high evolutionary call
me sire okay i'm pleased to be here as i gaze out
at this crowd i'm reminded of my sole purpose
in the universe to take unevolved disgusting
low-life scum such as yourselves and enhance
you genetically to something less reprehensible
thank you for inspiring me
with how vomitus you all are
the the bile in the back of my throat as
i look at you is all the motivation i need
to move forward and create the perfect species
they did confirm that he's going to be the
person who created rocket because he appears in
the trailer they show you rocket's origin story
i've done several videos about this before they
even had an easter egg for him during guardians
of the galaxy two sort of foreshadowing that
they would be doing him during guardians three
but the trailer footage just confirmed a lot of
our theories it high evolutionary will be the main
villain of the film like guardians of the galaxy
movies are all about bad space dads you have
thanos you have ego the living planet now you have
high evolutionary who's basically like rockets bad
dad the other big reveal they made was that maria
bacaloba is going to be playing a version of cosmo
in guardians 3. we saw a version of cosmo and
guardians 1 but james gunn said that one they
didn't have enough money and they were already
doing so many weird characters on the guardians
team he didn't want to also have a talking dog in
addition to a talking raccoon and a talking tree
so that's why cosmo was only an easter egg
in the collector's collection at the end of
the film this time it sounds like cosmo cosmo's
gonna be much bigger character and her origin
story also might be tied to rocket's origin story
like she also might have been modified by the high
evolutionary as well and that's why she might be
able to talk the trailer starts with the guardians
of the galaxy after the events of thor love and
thunder after a short time jump after they left
thor because there were so many random distressed
calls coming from all across the universe
all those different signals weren't meant to be
just from gore the god butcher's attacks but they
left to go pursue what they felt like was the
most important disaster that needed their help
and thor then left on his own to go see what
happened to sif so the first scene in the trailer
is happening way after that like after they've
already saved a bunch more random people and
these other signals that they detected they've
set a new appointment to meet the new leader
of the ravagers organization they're on their ship
the benatar it gets attacked and disabled and they
pull up on this giant other ship which is like the
ravager's main ship during the events of the movie
they open the airlock all the ravagers pull
weapons on them they're getting ready to shoot
them on site and peter quill has to try and calm
them down like we're one of you don't shoot us
don't shoot us we're also ravagers as well it
doesn't help and then nebula steps forward and
says we're here to see gamora and it just blows
peter quill's mind like he had no idea that the
new younger version of gamora from 2014 has become
the new leader of the ravagers since avengers end
game so now as a present day she's like badass
space pirate queen gamora at the beginning of the
movie then as you see peter quill's mind being
blown you see gamora walk through the ravagers
on their side of the airlock saying they're
early she does look like she has a few extra
city biles on her like she looks a little bit
different than you last saw her during avengers
end game her hair is a little bit longer it's a
little more unkempt and she has a new ravager's
jacket kind of like the ravager's jacket you
saw nebula wearing during thor love and thunder
then the flaming lip song do you realize kicks in
and plays across the rest of the entire trailer
as the camera pushes in on peter quill's reaction
to gamora the standard marvel studios logo comes
up in plays and because they haven't released
their next big movie or disney plus series yet
it was the same version that you saw during thor
love and thunder with like a little bit of miss
marvel footage a little bit of moon knight and a
little bit of doctor strange two footage in it but
then they did the same thing with the logo that
they did during the black panther wakanda forever
trailer where like everybody is now getting their
custom version of the logo for each new movie
and disney plus series so the traditional marvel
studios intro that you'd expect to see transitions
to like the custom guardians of the galaxy 3
version and it's like a white design fading into
red with the letters in the backdrop against what
looks like wood and the logo itself has this kind
of distressed weathered look as if it's chipping
off like paint i think the wood is meant to
represent the wood of groot's body they show some
new panning shots of the guardians of the galaxy
starting with peter quill he starts talking to
the new gamora saying that she was everything to
him and they show a flashback scene to the first
guardians of the galaxy movie guardians of the
galaxy vol 2 with them dancing on ego the living
planet you see the new gamora kind of reacting
to him telling her all these things there's a
separate scene of peter quill wearing a helmet
telling the new gamora that he misses her and she
responds by saying that other gamora wasn't me
then you see completely different scene of all
the guardians of the galaxy getting ready to jump
out the airlock wearing a bunch of spacesuits and
all the spacesuits are actually the colors of the
infinity stones with one exception like there's no
purple but there's a blue yellow orange green red
they jump out the hatch towards this giant
structure and this might be a version of
mcu half world because so much of the movie deals
with high evolutionary in rocket's origin story
and rocket comes from half world inside the mcu
they start transitioning to the guardians of the
galaxy 3 custom lettering style saying directed
by james gunn and then there's a new scene of
nebula looking up at that structure and then they
flash the new guardians of the galaxy 3 logo that
looks like this in front of her on the surface
so they make it look as if nebula is looking
at the new guardians 3 title in the title itself
transitions to the custom language that you saw in
the first guardians of the galaxy movie like this
custom alien language but it still says guardians
of the galaxy vol 3. there's a new scene of mantis
walking through their ship and then there's a
rocket raccoon flashback scene to his origin story
with a hand reaching out and touching a very small
baby version of rocket this is probably the high
evolutionary's hand getting ready to modify him
and enhance him with his cybernetic parts so that
he can talk and walk around on two legs like it's
a very scared tiny little baby version of rocket
sitting on all fours he looks like a regular
raccoon would look he doesn't have any of his
cybernetic parts yet they show you the back of the
high evolutionary's head with his special suit his
full suit looks like this like they show you his
face right after this but this is what he looks
like in broad daylight a little bit different
from the comic book version like he doesn't
have the face plate like he does in the comics
in the comics he actually started life as a normal
human called herbert wyndham and then eventually
became the high evolutionary his origin story in
the mcu might be a little bit different like he
looks humanoid but i don't know if they're gonna
say that he used to also be a human from earth
his comic book origin story interestingly enough
is actually connected to scarlet witch's origin
story 2. we'll see if there's any easter eggs
for that in the future of the mcu he used to
have a base that was in mount one dagor that was
connected to what was going on with cathode the
god of chaos chaos magic scarlet witch's origin
story i'm not completely expecting all those
connections with this version of the character
though they show you high evolutionary's lab
with all of his tools that look really wicked that
he uses to upgrade rocket and his other creations
there have been a lot of behind the scenes shots
of other animalistic looking characters that look
more humanoid now they were also probably modified
by the high evolutionary like we'll see a bunch of
other creations kind of like rocket but they'll
all be different types of animals and different
types of people that he's upgraded they show you
a first look at will poulter as adam warlock this
is what he looks like notice how he's got his
own special suit given to him by the sovereign
he's also got a gem inside his forehead like the
comics but it's not the soul stone like the comics
it's just a gold looking gem that's the same
color as the gold of his skin but the really
cool connection between adam warlock and high
evolutionary which they're both doing in the movie
is that high evolutionary in the comics is the one
who gave adam warlock the soul gem in his forehead
originally he didn't have that and he did that in
order to help adam warlock fight man beast and it
looks like a character in the movie is playing a
version of man beast so even though the plot of
the movie will be different from those comic book
stories they're doing some easter eggs for that
james gunn didn't reveal what was going on with
this new gemstone but it's probably just like
what they did with white vision giving him the
new control crystal in his forehead that was not
the soul gem like it was intended to replace the
soul gem the one that they gave the white vision
was just intended to be like a focusing crystal
that he used for attacks it's probably a similar
situation with adam warlock's gem it's probably
just another weapon that he can use or something
that he can use to amass more power overall he
looks great i wasn't sure what to expect but
this actually looks pretty fantastic there's a
couple quick shots of the new version of gamora
there's another new character that doesn't look
familiar but he also looks like he's been upgraded
by the high evolutionary you see what looks like
a regular suburban street on earth it might be a
flashback to peter quill's childhood because
all the cars look like they're from the 80s
you see a new version of peter quill drax and the
other guardians wearing the traditional guardians
costumes from the annihilation conquest comic book
run that was the run where this mcu version of
the team came together for the first time but
when they did the first guardians movie james
gunn kind of changed the story of how they came
together so this is them just going back to that
comic book deep cut there's a fight scene with
peter quill wearing that new comic book accurate
suit going back to back with groot firing their
weapons obviously groot doesn't fire weapons like
he just grows his parts it looks like groot starts
out being the same height as peter quill but then
in the middle of their fight grows bigger and
bigger and bigger so i think that's him just
teasing that he will grow back to his full size
in the movie vin diesel calls him alpha groot like
the most version of groot because then it zooms
in on groot's face and his face seems like it gets
older more mature and bigger than it seemed during
thor love and thunder there's a couple other
scenes of the guardians of the galaxy in their
infinity stone colored suits flying towards that
new half-world structure they show you a new scene
of the same type of creature from the beginning of
guardians of the galaxy 2 with the tentacles the
rows of teeth getting ready to attack there's a
couple flashes to scenes with other guardians
like nebula mantis all crying going crazy
and then it ends with peter quill talking to
the new version of gamora about opening yourself
up and the idea of family in general like he's
slowly trying to win over this version of gamora
back to the family so to speak they also said
a big part of the movie will be the nebula and
gamora story because the whole idea in the first
guardians of the galaxy movie was gamora trying
to save her sister because her sister nebula
was still kind of drinking the thanos kool-aid
now it's kind of flipped in reverse and
nebula is the one who's trying to save gamora
because it's coming out in may next year we'll
probably get the first trailer by like the end
of this year then probably some more trailers
when ant-man 3 quantum mania comes out because
it's like the next film after ant-man quantum
mania james gunn also revealed that this was the
last guardians of the galaxy mcu movie with this
roster of the team so in the comics i think the
whole idea is that they just cycled the roster the
guardians of the galaxy as a group will continue
but some of the characters will die some of them
will continue and they'll cycle in new characters
really good example of that is adam warlock now
in the mcu really op character in the comics
eventually he joins a version of the guardians
of the galaxy i think they might do that in the
movies but everyone post all your theories in the
comments below if you spotted any easter eggs in
the trailer footage that i didn't talk about in
the video just write it below in the comments
i've done a couple big videos about marvel phase
5 movies marvel phase 6 avengers 5 avengers 6 i'll
put links for that down in the description
below so you can learn all about that stuff
everyone click here for my full black panther
wakanda forever trailer video and easter eggs
and click here for my brand new ant-man 3
trailer in avengers 5 easter eggs thank you
so much for watching everyone stay safe
and i'll see you guys in the next one!